When you think about it, you probably receive
hundreds -- even thousands -- of cues about
what’s going on in your environment every
day, strictly from sound.
In addition to things like speech and music,
there are other bits of auditory information
that shape your day: an ambulance passing
by, a baby crying in the next room,
and of course [cell-phone style text ding goes off]
--
-- sorry.
Just got a text.
But there’s a lot that we can learn, not
just from what these cues MEAN, but from how
Sound itself works.
Studying sound waves has helped doctors learn
more about our ears, and has allowed engineers
to design things like microphones and speakers.
Biologists have even used the science of sound
to figure out how animals like elephants can
communicate over long distances -- when we
can’t even hear them doing it.
It all comes down to the fact that SOUND is
a wave, which travels through a medium like
air or water.
And knowing that sound is a wave is important,
because it means that we can use the physics
of waves to describe the qualities of sound.
[Intro Music Plays]
When you think of a wave, you probably think
of the kind you see at the ocean, or the ones
you made when you jumped on that trampoline
last time.
Those waves produce ripples that run perpendicular
to the direction, that the wave is traveling in.
But sound is the other kind of wave: it’s
a longitudinal wave, meaning that the wave’s
back-and-forth motion happens in the same direction in which the wave travels.
Say you get a text message on your phone,
and it makes a nice, bright little ‘ding!’ sound.
What actually happened? Like, on a physical level?
Your phone’s speaker contains a diaphragm
-- a piece of stiff material, usually in the
shape of a cone.
When you got the message, the electronics
inside the speaker made the diaphragm move
back and forth, which vibrated the air around
your phone.
That made the atoms and molecules in the air
move back and forth.
Then, those moving particles vibrated the
air around them -- and as the process continued,
the sound wave spread outward.
[ding!]
Sorry! I’m just gonna turn this off now.
Anyway, physicists sometimes describe sound
waves in terms of the movement of these particles
in the air -- in what’s known as a displacement
wave.
But by moving particles in the air, sound
waves also do something else:
They cause the air to compress and expand
-- which is why sound waves are sometimes
described as ‘pressure waves’.
As the wave spreads through the air, the particles
end up bunching together in some places, and
‘spreading out’ in others.
Together, all that bunching and spreading-out
causes areas of high pressure and low pressure
to form and move through the air.
It’s useful to describe sound waves as pressure
waves, because we can build devices that detect
those changes in pressure.
That’s how some microphones work, for example:
They use a diaphragm stretched over a sealed
compartment, and as sound waves pass by, they
create areas of lower or higher pressure in
the compartment.
The differences in pressure cause the diaphragm
to move back and forth, which electronics
then translate into audio data
And your eardrums basically work the same
way!
As pressure waves pass through, they make
your eardrum vibrate.
Your brain then interprets those vibrations
as sound.
But not all sounds are the same.
Even before we knew much about physics, humans
were describing sound in terms of certain qualities:
mainly, by things like ‘loudness’
and ‘pitch’.
Our understanding of those qualities helped
shape the development of music -- which we’ll
talk more about next time.
But there’s also a more physics-y side to
those qualities of music.
Pitch can be high or low, and it corresponds
to the ‘frequency’ of the wave.
So, air that’s vibrating back and forth
more times per second will have a higher pitch,
and air that’s vibrating fewer times per
second will have a lower pitch.
Humans hear sounds best when the vibrations
are somewhere between 20 per second on the
low end and 20,000 per second on the high
end.
As we get older and lose more of the cells
that help us detect sound, we start to lose
the ability to hear higher-pitched sounds.
Some building security companies will take
advantage of this, using devices that emit
a high-pitched noise that most people over
the age of 25 can’t hear.
The idea is that since kids and teens can
hear it, and it’s super annoying to them,
they won’t hang out near the building.
But some sounds are too high or low for any
humans to hear.
Sounds that are too high in pitch are called
ultrasonic, and sounds that are too low are
called infrasonic.
Dog whistles, for example, use an ultrasonic
pitch that’s too high for us, but is perfectly
audible to dogs.
Elephants, on the other hand, use INFRAsonic
sound to communicate with each other across
long distances.
They can hear these calls from several kilometers
away, but we can’t hear them at all.
Another aspect that shapes sound is its loudness
-- when you increase the intensity of a sound,
you increase its loudness, and vice versa.
We’ve talked about the intensity of a wave
before: it’s the wave’s power over its
area, measured in Watts per square meter.
We’ve also said that the intensity of a
wave is proportional to the wave’s amplitude, squared.
And the farther you are from the source of
a wave, the lower its intensity -- by the
square of the distance between you and the
source.
And just as there’s a range of pitches that
humans can hear, there’s also a range of
sound wave intensity that humans can comfortably
hear.
Generally, people can safely hear sounds from
about 1 picowatt per square meter,
up to 1 Watt per square meter -- which is about as loud as a rock concert, if you’re near the speakers.
The sound waves coming from a jet plane that’s
30 meters away, for example, probably has
an intensity of around 100 Watts per square
meter.
Now, I don’t know if you’ve ever been
that close to a roaring jet plane.
But there’s a reason people who work on
the tarmac at airports use those heavy-duty headphones.
Below 1 picowatt per square meter, sounds
are just too soft for us to detect them.
And although we will HEAR sounds above a Watt
per square meter, they tend to hurt our ears.
But here’s a weird thing about loudness
and intensity: it’s not a linear relationship.
Generally, a sound wave needs to have ten
times the intensity to sound twice as loud to us.
This relationship holds true as long as the
sound is toward the middle of the range of
frequencies we can hear.
So, instead of directly measuring the loudness
of sounds by their intensity, we use units
called ‘decibels’ -- which are based on
bels.
Bels convert a sound wave’s intensity to
a ‘logarithmic scale’, where every notch
on the scale is ten times higher than the
previous one.
The scale starts off with an intensity of
1 picowatt per square meter, corresponding
to 0 bels.
So a sound that’s 1 bel is ten times as
intense as a sound that’s 0 bels.
And a sound that’s 2 bels is 10 times as
intense as a sound that’s 1 bel --
-- but 100 times as intense as a sound that’s
0 bels.
Measuring everything in bels can be kind of
annoying, because sometimes you want to talk
about sounds that are, say, 3.4 bels without
having to deal with decimal points.
That’s why most of the time, you’ll hear
the loudness of a sound described using the
more familiar decibel unit -- a tenth of a
bel.
To find the loudness of a sound when you know
its intensity, you take the base-10 logarithm
of its intensity, over the reference intensity
of 1 picowatt per square meter.
Then, you multiply that number by 10 to get
the sound’s decibel level.
We can use this equation to convert the intensity
of that noisy rock concert -- which we said
was 1 Watt per square meter -- to decibels.
First, we take the base 10 log of 1 Watt per
square meter, over 1 picowatt per square meter.
Now, 1 divided by 1 x 10^-12 is just 1 x 10^12.
So what we really want to do is take the base
10 log of 1 x 10^12 -- or a trillion -- watts
per square meter.
What a logarithm asks you to do, is find the
power that you would need to raise the base
to in order to get the number in parentheses.
In other words, we’re looking for the exponent
of 10 that would equal 1 x 10^12.
Which is just 12.
To finish off the calculation of decibels
from intensity, we multiply that value -- 12
-- by 10 to get the decibel level of the rock
concert, where you were standing: 120 decibels.
Ouch.
You’ll notice that as the source of a sound
moves closer to you, it gets louder, and as
it moves away, it gets softer.
That makes sense, since the closer you are
to the source of a sound, the greater the
intensity of the wave that hits your ear.
But have you ever noticed that the pitch of
the sound changes, too?
It’s called the ‘Doppler effect’: As
a source of sound moves toward you, the pitch
of the sound you hear increases.
And as the source moves away, the pitch decreases.
To see why, imagine you’re standing on the
sidewalk, when suddenly you hear an ambulance
siren start up.
It’s coming from down the road, and it seems
to be moving toward you.
The ambulance is continuously emitting sound
waves at a certain frequency, in the form
of that siren.
But as the ambulance moves toward you, the
ambulance is also driving toward those sound waves.
So, the peaks that hit your eardrums are closer
together -- even though they’re moving at
the same speed -- and you get hit by them
more often.
Which means you hear a higher-pitched sound.
At the same time, it keeps emitting more sound,
which adds more peaks to those earlier sound
waves that are heading your way.
What you end up with, is a sound wave with
a higher frequency than before.
That’s what hits your eardrum, so you hear
a sound that’s higher in pitch than the
one you heard before the ambulance started
moving.
As the ambulance passes you and starts to
drive away down the road, the opposite happens.
The sound waves are still coming toward you,
but the ambulance is driving away from them.
So the peaks that hit your eardrum are farther
apart, and you hear a sound with a lower pitch.
The Doppler effect isn’t unique to sound
waves, though -- it happens with light, too.
Which means we can actually use it to measure
the distance of stars -- but more on that much later.
For now, you learned about sound waves, and
how they move particles back and forth to
create differences in pressure.
We also talked about pitch, and how the intensity
of a sound wave changes with amplitude and distance.
Finally, we covered decibels, as well as the
Doppler effect.
Crash Course Physics is produced in association
with PBS Digital Studios.
You can head over to their channel to check
out amazing shows like Gross Science,
PBS Idea Channel, and It's Okay to be Smart.
This episode of Crash Course was filmed in
the Doctor Cheryl C. Kinney Crash Course Studio
with the help of these amazing people and
our equally amazing graphics team is Thought Cafe.